يحتقطع الاحذيه الرياضيه القسم الاكبر من
سوق العالمي للاحذيه كونها مريحه من جهه
وايضا زادت الاهتمام بالموضوعات الصحه
واللياقه البدنيه منصه اندكس بوكس
بمفردها في العام 2019 على
31.6% من السوق فيما حصل العلامه
الالمانيه اديداس على 21.7% اذا السوق
محتكر من الشركات الكبيره لكن لماذا لان
تكاليفه عاليه وتتوزع على كلفه التشغيل
المصانع البحث والتطوير الترويج والتسويق
وهذا ما يفسر صعوب الدخول وافدين جدد
الابحا تشير الى ان مازال من التوسع في
السنوات القادمه بدعوه عوامل متعدده
افرازها زياده عدد السكان وارتفاع متوسطه
الدخل الفردي بالاضافه الى نمو التجاره
الالكترونيه التي ستسمح بالاصول الى
مستهلكين من جميع انحاء العالم ومن
المنتظر النسائيه بسرعه اكبر من سوق
الاحذيه الرجاليه وذلك بسبب الارتفاع
المستمر في اعداد النساء التي تدخل سوق
العمل